le pirate avait inspecté la maladie pendant des
générations, alors j'ai déposé une note de service et
[Musique]
puis il y avait ce garçon
oui mais le
jeu modèle de Rome,
il m'a tout pris
et rempli de
rage
[Applaudissements]
J'ai entendu dire que
le puissant capitaine espagnol avec cent
il a tué des milliers  des hommes vivent une autre
fenêtre par l'Iran je vais te suspendre de faire
quelque chose en espagnol
devenant une future merde personnelle ton équipage
le chemin regarde je suis vraiment désolé nous parlons toujours
il n'y a pas de spirale de combat de mots
pour moi à
partir de ce moment nous sommes moi une ligne qui
sautille  façon tout ce temps parce
qu'ils étaient des singes les plus fous
ne cherchant pas les ennuis horrible Lena
Lena
tu paies pour ce que tu m'as fait
minimiser les soins en cherchant Jack je
vais nager pour ça Kareena arrête ça
non non non non c'est allé loin  assez
pas d'attente hip-hop j'ai vu ses chevilles tu
descends beaucoup plus si tu
gardes ton coup de cakehole
[Musique]